If you're following anything that's going
on in America right now, you're either watching
a Bernie Sanders running for president or
you're watching Donald Trump.
And generally, the Bernie Sanders following
can't stand this guy [pointed at Donald Trump
hat], and the Trump following, doesn't like
this guy [pointed at Bernie Sanders t-shirt].
However, these guys have a lot more in common
than they think they do.
But before I get into this, let me tell you
how completely opposite this is if you're
watching this and you're not from America.
This is kind of like, people who love cats
vs. dogs.
Dog lovers maybe not liking cats.
Yankees fans against Redsox -- a pure contradiction,
Droid users vs. iPhone -- obviously, we know
the greatest phone.
And then you have Bernie vs. Trump.
But these two, have a lot more in common than
you think they do.
And let me tell you exactly what it is.
You see, there's a lot entrepreneurs can learn
from Bernie, and a lot they can learn from
Trump.
Let me tell you what it is.
You see, the most important person in an entrepreneur's
life when you're building your business, you
are seeking a vote.
Your voter is the customer.
The way they vote, is by purchasing your product.
When they buy your product, and they exchange
money with you, that is a vote.
You got a vote from them, right?
Now, the reason why I like what's happening
with these two guys is this.
Neither one of these guys have gone to the
establishment, and in the world of politics,
the establishment are the people who decide
who becomes the nominee.
The establishment is the one that says, "Here's
Hillary Clinton; she should be the nominee.
Here's Ted Cruz, Jeb Bush, he should be the
nominee."
Not Trump, not Bernie Sanders.
Now they [Trump and Sanders] go after somebody
else, because they're going after the voter.
They don't listen to the establishment; they're
listening to the voter.
And the voter is responding to them.
Both of them have gotten millions of donors.
I want to say that Hillary Clinton has gotten
roughly 1.3 million donors.
I think Bernie Sanders has 8 million donors
that have bought something on his website
or donated to his campaign.
But Hillary has a lot more money because she
has the establishment.
Bernie does not.
Trump doesn't have the establishment; he got
voters that said, "We want you" and he just
won the nominee.
They are the disrupters.
Bernie and Trump are the disrupters.
Now, Bernie on one hand is a Democratic socialist
is what he's campaigning with.
He wants to give a lot of free programs and
take care of people in the way that he believes
is best, and Trump is a Republican capitalist.
He believes in certain principles that are
just the opposite of these guys.
But what they're doing, their fundamental
approach to getting the vote is very similar.
They're both disrupting.
Now keep this in mind.
In an industry as an entrepreneur, a Jeff
Bezos is a disrupter.
An Elon Musk is a disrupter.
Let me explain why.
Elon Musk goes in the oldest business that
no one's been touching or has been able to
compete in for decades.
You don't hear a lot of new car companies
coming out.
You don't.
You saw Fisker come out; it didn't work.
You saw all these other companies come out,
and it didn't work out.
Then Tesla came out.
Then he places an order of 300,000 cars.
And you see the price of gas going down, that's
disrupting.
Why does the establishment not like Elon Musk?
Because there's a lot of people that make
money when there's oil involved.
There's so much politics in oil.
I'm in Texas.
Politics involved in oil.
Middle East.
OPEC, voters, control.
. . there's so much, we have to make sure
the world counts on oil, and Elon Musk says,
"We don't need gas stations.
I'm going to put chargers all over America
and it's going to be free of charge.
You don't need to pay for it."
You're kidding me!
"No, I'm serious.
I'm going to put them everywhere.
It's on me, don't worry about it.
Free charge."
Disrupt!
Jeff Bezos says, "I know we've been reading
books for all this time and we grab a book,
here's what we've been doing, we've been reading
books all this time.
All these years, this is how books have been.
They've been print.
This is trees, just so you know this."
Jeff Bezos says, "We don't need to waste trees
anymore."
Jeff Bezos saves trees.
That's insane!
He says we're going to read ebooks.
We don't need Borders.
Borders goes out of business.
Barnes and Noble is shutting down all over
the place.
Traditional bookstores.
Trees being saved.
More oxygen, better weather, and at the same
time he says, books are going to be gone.
Bezos = disrupter.
Steve Wozniak and Steve Jobs -- everybody
ought to have a computer.
No, no, no, no no.
The first computer Philadelphia - you know,
one night when you turned on the computer
the city's electricity shut down because it
required so much power.
No.
Everyone needs to have a computer.
We can't do that!
We can't let people have so much control.
Let everybody have a computer.
Everybody needs to have a cell phone.
Smartphones.
Everybody!
It shouldn't just be the rich people.
Everybody.
Disrupters, right?
I could go on and on and on with disrupters;
they're are many of them here.
Trump, Elon Musk, Bernie Sanders, are disrupting
the establishment.
The reason why the establishment doesn't like
disrupters is because money goes through a
lot of people.
I'm in the financial industry.
and in my industry, there are certain things
in the insurance world that a lot of the money
is being shared.
Way too many people that get a piece of the
money before a policy is approved.
We're working on disrupting that entire industry
in a way that's never been done before.
We're disrupting the industry.
A lot of people don't like that, that we're
shaking things up a little bit, and they're
getting upset about it.
"Hey, who is this Patrick Bet-David guy thinking
he can disrupt a boring life insurance industry
that's been around for thousands of years?
Who is this Middle Eastern guy from Iran who
is running a business, thinking he's going
to disrupt us.
We don't like this guy."
But we're growing, and we're going to disrupt
this industry because it needs to be disrupted.
This [the establishment] needs to be disrupted.
The corporate establishment needs to be disrupted.
They can't control Bernie.
He doesn't want their money.
They can't control Trump.
Now they have to listen.
If they don't listen, he's the nominee.
Now I don't know if Bernie is going to be
the nominee or not; he's been winning most
of the states recently, but he doesn't get
the super delegates.
(That's a whole different conversation!)
So now let's get to this.
What is disrupting?
First of all, let me bring it to the lowest
level so it may be easier to understand.
I know this is a stereotype, but if you are
raised in a Middle Eastern family or let's
just say an Asian family, hypothetically.
You know, there's stereotypes; I heard them
all the time growing up.
You either need to be a doctor, a lawyer,
or a engineer.
If you're not one of those three things, you're
not good.
If you don't go to school, you're not good.
If you don't have a 4-year degree from UCLA
or UC Irvine or USC, you're not good.
You went to Cal State?
Ohhhh, you didn't go to.
. . ? There is this whole thing.
Then all of a sudden, someone in the family
says, "I'm going to disrupt."
"What do you mean you're going to disrupt?"
"I don't want to do the school thing!
I'm not going to college!
I'm going to be an entrepreneur."
To your family, you're a disrupter.
You disrupted that family, and you became
an entrepreneur.
That is a level of disruption.
Why don't most people want to be disrupters?
Well, because in order to be validated as
a disrupter, you have to go through three
phases.
And that phase requires you to go through
heat.
Most people don't like the heat.
And most people cannot handle the heat.
Entrepreneurs, there are a lot of different
levels.
We can call ourselves entrepreneurs and there's
the disrupters.
History books write about disrupters.
People write about disrupters.
People study disrupters.
People want to be disrupters.
People admire disrupters.
People hate disrupters!
People love disrupters!
There's a certain level of admiration for
disrupters.
There's three phase you have to go through.
#1: Ridicule.
When Trump got up and said, "I'm running for
President!"
People said he was out of his mind, and that
he was just doing it because he wanted marketing
campaign dollars.
There's no way in the world!
Everybody ridiculed, laughed, all these comics,
all this stuff.
Bernie Sanders, "I'm running for president!"
Against Hillary Clinton?
You're out of your mind!
You don't stand a chance!
He started at 7%, 17%, 27, 37.
Holy moly. 8 million, 9 million people donated
to Bernie Sanders campaign?
Are you out of your mind?
He was ridiculed.
Phase #2: Violently opposed.
Violently opposed is people coming outside
your campaign, people coming out doing things,
doing things to your car, doing things to
your name, negative, all this other stuff
that happens.
Level #3: Self-Evident.
The self-evident part is when everybody says,
"Oh we always knew he was going to do it.
Everybody knew Trump was going to do it.
I mean, c'mon, it's Donald Trump.
Everybody knew Bernie Sanders, everybody knew.
Everybody knew Jeff Bezos.
Everybody knew Elon Musk -- it's Elon Musk!
High IQ.
His mom's a model.
Everybody knew.
Everybody knew Steve Jobs.
Not everybody knew!
Most people never saw the first two phases
that they went through.
Very few people witnessed the first two phases.
This is the heat.
Can you handle the heat, when you're distrupting
an industry?
Can you?
When you do, as an entrpreneur, now will you
vote for this guy [Bernie]?
Or this guy [Trump], or if you're living in
Malaysia or Brazil or China or Russia or Germany
(people from 225 different countries view
these videos), it doesn't matter whether you
even know this guy [Bernie] or this guy [Trump].
Their politics are complete opposite.
I mean, when I tell you complete opposite,
it's COMPLETE opposite.
But they're both disrupting their establishment.
And as an entrepreneur, sometimes you have
to be brave enough to disrupt an industry.
Because 5, 10, 20, 30 years later, many of
the new things that they'll use happen because
somebody had the courage to disrupt that industry,
just like these two guys had the courage to
disrupt the establishment, who thinks they
control who the next president of the United
States needs to be, and not the voter.
Forget what the voter thinks.
Forget what the customer says.
Forget these guys.
They don't know what they're talking about.
No, no, no.
We know who's the best president for you.
Disrupters say, "No one knows better than
the guys who vote."
We need to think about what they're [voters]
thinking about.
America is telling these guys [Trump and Sanders],
"We like you more and trust you more than
the establishment.
Slightly different message, but it is a message
that has to do with entrepreneurs.
If you've got questions about it, comment
on the bottom, if you have thoughts, comment
on the bottom.
If you haven't subscribed to this crazy channel
where we talk about entrepreneurship, and
every once in a while.
. . I'm actually wearing a Donald Trump hat.
Mario, we're really doing this, aren't we?
I'm wearing a Bernie Sanders shirt.
My family's going to say, "Pat, you're completely
confused."
But I hope the message wasn't confusing.
[Mario: "They're going to say, 'you're fired!'"]
[Patrick laughs.]
"They're going to say, "I'm fired!" is what
they're going to say.
Hey, if you haven't subscribed to the channel,
please do so, and if you watch this video
some other place, not on YouTube or my website,
you can always to visit PatrickBetDavid.com.
Thanks for watching, take care everybody,
bye bye.